[Music]
so Hollywood is crawling with outsiders
and foreigners and if we kick them all
out you'll have nothing to watch but
football and mixed martial arts which
Meryl Streep delivered a stirring
acceptance speech at the Golden Globe
Sunday evening criticizing president
elect Donald Trump and taking a minor
dig at mixed martial arts MMA president
Scott Coker took to Twitter to invite
the actress to a fight and wrote in part
Meryl I'm a lifelong fan of your work
but also a lifelong martial artist the
global sport of mixed martial arts
celebrates male and female athletes from
all around the world who work years
tirelessly honing their craft and yes
art disrespect invites disrespect
violence incites violence when the
powerful uses their position to bully
others we all lose president-elect Trump
also responded to marrow speech where
she admitted she was stunned when he
reportedly imitated a disabled reporter
he shut down those claims tweeting Meryl
Streep one of the most overrated
actresses in Hollywood doesn't know me
but attacked last night at the Golden
Globes
she is a Hillary flunky who lost big and
Billy Eichner blasted Fox News host
megyn McCain who tweeted that Meryl
speech is why Trump won and will help
him get reelected the comedian fired
back saying McCain was a [ __ ] and wrote
quote I'd rather live in a bubble than
live with people who don't feel a need
to respect the disabled freedom of
speech and the arts